now dozens of people are reported to
being killed in a major fire at an
apartment Block in the Vietnamese
Capital Hanoi well State media says that
many others have been taken to hospital
The Blaze is said to have started just
before midnight on Tuesday
or Jessica Washington joins us live on
the phone now from Kanto in Vietnam or
Jessica what more can you tell us
well this is silly developing situation
I'll just talk you through the
information that we have at this stage
as you said State media says that
thousands have been killed still no
clarity as to exactly how many victims
there are we've seen some pictures
showing rescue workers carrying out
victims what we've heard is that the
glaze started around 17 GMT and was
contained within a few hours around 70
individuals were rescued among them 54
people rushed to hospital according to
Vietnam's official news agency this was
a serious fire and it took place in a
residential area in Southwest
fatalities as I mentioned still unclear
have also heard from some of the health
workers assisting in that effort of
helping those who were injured in this
fire a doctor from a local hospital
nearby said that some of the survivors
were in a situation of being in extreme
distress one patient had is spinal
injuries from falling out of the
building and a mother and her baby were
also suffering from severe smoke
inhalation and just to give you some
context here of building fires in
Vietnam last year a fire in karaoke bar
killed more than 30 people in Ho Chi
Minh City
17 others were injured and so the
context here is that these building
fires do take place rather often here in
Vietnam and in in this particular
instance local authorities have been
urged by the central government to
deploy all resources police have already
begun their investigation as to the
cause of the fire some witnesses said
that they saw the fire start in the
parking lot the other context here is
that in a densely populated city like
Hanoi people are living in very crowded
Close Quarters and safety considerations
are often perhaps put to the side as
people are living very densely packed
and some buildings often don't have the
safety standards that perhaps would be
ideal buildings would perhaps limited
Escape Routes or indeed situations where
people have put bars on their windows so
that's just sort of the general context
for this situation this is still a
developing situation uh and in terms of
fatalities we do hope to hear some clear
information from authorities incoming
albums Jessica for now thanks very much
indeed for that update